defined by destruction and displacement
this is the daily routine of thousand of
Palestinians fleeing the war in the
northern part and the Gaza City but this
time these thousand of people are
pouring into from the central part of
the Gaza Strip as the Israeli military
just stepped up its military operations
and widened the intensity and the scale
of the bombings and Order thousand of
people to leave the central part all the
way to come to Al maasi area at the
Western of RAF again designating it as a
safe Zone people here you know there is
no safe place in the Gaza Strip not even
this small area of largely sand
part we decided to go directly to Rafa
City instead of going to De Bala because
we knew it wasn't safe and we would be
told to evacuate there's no safe place
in Gaza we don't know where to go after
this
place people left under heavy shelling
there were people who had been killed on
the Saladin Road as they were evacuating
from narat magazi Burge camp zidi and
derbala City all left for the South so
in each passing day the bombings
intensity increases to the point that
people had no other choice but to leave
the central part of the Gaza Strip all
the way Tak a journey into Rafa City
near the Egyptian Gaza Border in an
attempt to save their lives in one of
these small tents that they will set up
so far thousand of people have arrived
here we're expecting more in the coming
hours Hy Mahmud Al jazer evacuation Zone
Rafa
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer